and ponder the question
what if
yes we send it every time but we haven't
yet taken this intro to task for
breaking the one minute rule yet by the
time we get to the actual episode one
minute and 45 seconds have passed almost
two full minutes of preliminary logo
lashing and title trouncing before we
see a frame of new content we've said it
before and we'll say it again you get
one minute tv shows anymore and cindy
brings down the sin hammer is it cool if
i take a picture with you yes but it is
not okay to carry your camera around
with a full zoom erection at the ready
like this and here's another minute of
just repeating the beginning of iron man
with almost no changes it's like my dad
always said if you didn't add any new
wrinkles why did you have to re-iron man
in fact the only thing the show removes
is the ever relevant myspace joke i'm
about to move you out of my top eight
marvel today
it appears as if random soldier guy gets
taken out with some sort of shotgun with
huge shot pellets and a wide dispersion
and my question is how did tony not
catch even a scratch from any of that
shot that went through these holes also
it appears they're traveling in the
middle of the day so how would the light
source be low enough for this kind of
light dispersion the angle puts it right
here which honestly looks to be below
the mountainous horizon but it looks
really cool so i guess
science yeah granite along with luke's
binary sunset and the falling dude
hitting the propeller on the titanic
this is one of the greatest shots in
movie history but the more you show it
the more you risk annoying us it's like
that one well-endowed guy in gym class
who spends as much time naked as
possible in the locker room we get it
man you can put that thing away now we
just watched a handball instructional
video today not sure why you need the
shower mr stark were you injured in the
attack no but i did spill my drink and
it was a 26 mcallen so i'm pretty sure
that's a war crime drinking a vehicle
excuse me sir harry wedding to the
british post the british post that
doesn't even exist sure there was a
tabloid called the post that had a
whopping five issues in 1998 but those
crazy brits called their mail the post
so that didn't even make sense we're
watching you harry whittington at least
come up with a better fake name
whittington i think that's a real thing
since on the day of the attack his unit
was stationed 400 clicks away using the
term click come on to you military you
thought you could get away with going to
the metric system by saying a cool word
like click instead of kilometer not in
my america
ah i never liked that guy when did happy
turn into such an aggressive grouch is
happy named grumpy in this universe are
there other universes where he's sleepy
or sneezy release the dopey gut you're
butch i'm sundance just so we're clear
paul newman shaming this is my doctoral
thesis i developed plans for automated
combat drone an easily searchable mit
doctoral thesis in a database that
pepper somehow hadn't been able to find
bullsh
you saved my life i'd like to return the
favor and giving him a job wasn't enough
of a returning the favor for you worst
case scenario we'll end up with the
world's most expensive gundam model you
joke but that model is about as gundam
as it gets they probably told some
lackey to design something that felt
like gundam and they were like or i
could just upload an actual gundam and
spend the rest of my day shopping for
hard to get 4k steelbooks on ebay crates
delegation drink breaks swipe and
scrunch disco dismemberment sparks
soldering staring punching excitement oh
oh no foreplay eh it's a waste of time
anyway
you take that back sir you take that
back
now that i know you mean business we can
move on to the good stuff which is why
foreplay is so important [ __ ] what are
they teaching in schools these days
killmonger you got eyes on this
killmonger ah yes continue to vocalize
your ally's name so enemies can easily
hear smirt so smeared the amount of
panic firing happening in these metal
close quarters calls into question
everyone's intelligence including the
writers who allowed the dumb to ricochet
around the script stark r d is no joke
the sonic taser thing is legit yep stark
r d will provide you with whatever story
ammunition and plot armor you need need
black panther to die we'll bring back
the sonic taser it's like an easy button
for squeezing a bunch of complex plot
movements into 25 minutes these entirely
two large pockets sometimes the real
world sneaks into our fantasy
entertainment and the loss of chadwick
is honestly making this black panther
funeral hit on a pretty deep level sends
off for a legend gone too soon what do
you say to killers actually in this case
you could toast to having a killer robot
who instead of finishing the job when he
has the target in hand decides to toss
him out and play with him a little more
for reasons
your moves are his moves we call that
same versus same around here tony and
then we sent it fit character loses
clothing in a ridiculous way so the
audience can bask in the sexy hand we're
not complaining and the show will
pretend it's about the kill count tats
but that doesn't mean the real reason
isn't nakedly obvious cliche this
sequence did not start with 13 years
later which is how long it should have
taken for all these massive weapons to
have been created congratulations
lieutenant you just invented 21st
century warfare with what killer drones
we've been doing those since the 20th
century i know these ones walk instead
of fly but remind me again exactly how
that's an upgrade yes
yes
yes stealing daniel bryan's catchphrase
wakandans are full of
surprises what khan division i come with
a gift an offering of justice
sure but how did you get in here and why
exactly are the dora milaje meeting you
here in this oh so cinematic middle of
nowhere oh please they're built by
americans we'll be home in time for
lunch that's mericus the drones operate
via a hive matrix how does she know any
of this they spelled borg wrong also
these cars followed the flow of the
arrows past their parking spot and then
forced anyone behind them to wait while
they backed in like [ __ ] i want a
little bit more than that
a button a button the droids are cut off
from whatever nonsense matrix they use
but this easy button key fob [ __ ]
powers them up via a backup transmitter
where when how this episode is trying to
do all the narrative work of a full
movie but the condensed run time makes
it all feel unearned and silly a button
force field shields powering up on one
side and an army of droids with pointy
heads easily deactivated on the other
side this battle of naboos so hard i
think jar jar just became an official
member of the avengers killmonger leaps
from a legend lands on a war rhino at
the front of the pack and how exactly do
physics work in wakanda or better
question where did he jump from there's
no tall balcony behind him as he rides
away also i genuinely need a primer on
wakanda battle rhino use they're all
suited up for this skirmish with some
battle droids but in infinity war they
left them in the stables and yes i know
this is a different universe but that
doesn't make this any less confusing
does marvel even know how to end
anything without a big fighter battle
when do we get the marvel that ends with
a rom-com wedding or murder mystery
reveal or bollywood dancing number boy
it sure is nice of the wardroids to stop
attacking so that our beloved characters
can have a battle bonding beat we cut
back to captain grumpy pants as if he's
been watching this whole thing unfold
but did he ever even get the signal back
did the easy button somehow restore his
view too despite being outside of the
shield i have no idea how any of this
works and i paid for this with my
existing disney plus subscription so
it's my right to know every single
detail venting your anger on the letter
e i'm getting heavy screaming cowboy
vibes off the watcher here and now i'm
sending the show for getting that i'm
gonna go with song stuck in my head
again with this herb
you shall become
the next black panther drinking the
purple stuff instead of the sunny d
what how did you get in here better
question how did she turn herself around
in a dramatic reveal when her feet can't
touch the floor and her hands are in her
lap
it's made with bits of real panther so
you know it's good but don't you worry
about that i brought receipts thank you
and this is my receipt for your receipt
we'll be like butch and sundance well
the way i figured we need to fight or
give
if we give we go to jail i've been there
already
oh oh no foreplay
you know what it's a waste of time
anyway no no no no more foreplay
ouch time
tommy
how's it peeping
[Music]
you got knocked the [ __ ] out man do you
know how to use that thing
yeah
pointy end goes into the other men
rhynox maximize